I like my thirties away more than my 20s
twenties were horrible and seven in my
teens was fun but I like 30 30s great
Britney Spears has lived learned and is
admitting to Lorraine TVs a Dan Wooten
that she did not love her 20s or some
back story right around Britney's 21st
Justin Timberlake released the infamous
Crimea River music video featuring a
Brit Brit look-alike
but that wasn't the only controversy of
Brittany's twenties in 2004 she married
Jason Alexander in Vegas only to have
the marriage annulled 55 hours later
that same year she got hitched to Kevin
Federline they had two sons before
divorcing in 2007 Britt also had a brief
stint in rehab in 2007 the next night
she shaved her head and soon lost a
physical custody of her children
but today Britney is back on top
her new album glory is one of her best
and partially inspired by another young
artist when I listen to a lot of like
Selena Gomez I just think her vibes look
really really cool in Moody and sexy so
I wanted to kind of play in the bat a
little bit keep my hands to myself
you